Jeff Duncan he is the beat writer for
the pelicans New Orleans times-picayune
congratulations Jeff you won last night
thanks Dan yeah the city's still trying
to still trying to figure this thing out
I don't think most people in New Orleans
right now truly believe what happened
last night I think they think it's an
absinthe induced figment of their
imagination all right I couldn't help
but wonder where Anthony Davis was last
night and as anybody talked to him last
night or today I believe that some
reports are already leaking out that I
have not talked to him but some people
have reported that his stance has not
changed I know David Griffin the
director of basketball ops and the new
director of basketball ops for the
pelicans has plans to meet with Anthony
Davis and his representation the rich
ball at some point here in the near
future I'm sure now that's going to be
accelerated for him to sit down and and
try and talk to him and see if his 9:00
has changed and I would have to think
and that last night's news you know if
he's not intrigued by that possibility
of teaming with Zion Williams and Andrew
holiday here I don't know what would get
him intrigued because I think that
Trillo would would do some serious
damage in the Western Conference
what about Julius Randall's future
that's up in the air that's one of many
decisions that David Griffin has to make
on the roster along with Alfred Payton a
number of players I mean really one of
the attractive things for David Griffin
coming here is he almost has a clean
slate with the roster I know that could
be viewed good or bad but it really is a
clean slate and new ownership here with
Gail Benson I think has made this a very
attractive situation for someone that is
in is embracing a challenge of a rebuild
you really have to have really a no
baggage on the roster to move forward
I'm trying to figure out this is it
better if Anthony Davis stays or you
trade him to the Lakers or Boston and
and then you just do a complete redo
here and you just start over and bring
in younger players ready to go who want
to be there there's but which one makes
more sense to you well I think there was
some major damage done by Davis and his
camp with the way the trade request was
made the public stance that was taken
and and I think they would have to do
some damage control look they're fans
right eventually that would wear off
with every dunk and wind Anthony Davis
would bring to the organization but
there are there is a segment of the fan
base here that is ready to say goodbye
to Auntie Davis and move forward and I
think that is ultimately the path that
David Griffin will take and you know use
a game of Thrones reference he's on the
Iron Throne right now I mean he has a
lot of capital to work with now with
Zion Davis he as I limps in here I think
it makes it a more attractive
organization to more free agents as well
much less when he gets in this trade for
Anthony Davis
McLovin could you translate what Jeff
just said about the iron throne place
who's in charge
okay all right so he's in charge aren't
ya if I'm New Orleans I move on from
Anthony Davis as wonderful as he is but
if he doesn't want to be there and then
if you get a package deal from the
Lakers and you can get a couple of those
kids who are ready to play right now and
you come in I think it could be really
exciting and we found that Sion he seems
like the ultimate team player he was he
was it Duke he was a great team player I
just hope he he the city will envelop
him I hope he gets that he has an open
mind to want to want to play there
because it's there wonderful people and
it's a wonderful city and it could be
you know the started something really
spectacular I just don't want it to be a
redo of 2012 where you know Anthony Dave
or you know he was in this situation too
and then somehow you know wanted to get
out of town well I think Dan the one
thing that Zion linson has over Anthony
Davis is first of all his games got such
sizzle to it he's got a radiant
personality like
said a very humble kid which is amazing
considering all the hype and hoopla that
accompanied his career everyone you
talked to by all accounts he's very
selfless and humble and I think he's
gonna like you said immediately be
embraced by New Orleans fans he's the
perfect player in this market at this
time for the city of New Orleans this is
a traditional football town
basketball is never really taken off all
the way back you'd have to go back to
the 70s when Pistol Pete was here before
you really found someone that the city
wrapped itself around and loved on the
basketball court I think this kid will
be that player because of that the way
he plays in his game he's at he's at
like Elvis on the basketball court in
New Orleans kind of needs that it's a
big event town it loves its Superstars
Drew Brees of course in football they
brace Reggie Bush and I think Dan
Williams will be that in basketball
certainly has the best opportunity to do
that here where were you last night when
you heard that announcement I was out on
the lake front in New Orleans on Lake
Pontchartrain and the entire restaurant
first off out of its seats people were
hugging and celebrating damn that
doesn't happen in May in New Orleans
with basketball that's something you'd
see at a Saints game not with the
pelicans storyline it was amazing people
were pull out their cell phones and you
know taking selfies I haven't seen
anything quite like it regarding
basketball and I've been here two
decades if you were going to recommend
one restaurant as I am day one when he
comes to town absolutely no doubt in my
mind Clancy's in Uptown New Orleans
quintessential New Orleans fare and
service great room great atmosphere one
of one of Gregg Popovich's favorites
when he comes to town he's always at
Clancy's the night before game Paulie we
went there when we went to the Sugar
Bowl didn't we yes we had an afternoon
brunch lunch thing but when I think it's
Oklahoma LSU Sugar Bowl we went there
really nice huh there you go
we're providing all the services
for zion Williamson hey Jeff thanks for
joining us have fun with this and I'm
certain we'll be in touch
yeah Dan thanks for having me on it's
gonna be a fun fun ride here in New
Orleans
that's Jeff Duncan the pelicans beat
writer for the New Orleans
times-picayune for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]